So, what we're going to
do now, is we're going to
write a simple application,
that gives gifts to our friends.
And the first thing that we're
going to need to do then,
if we're going to give gifts to
our friends, is we need to
know who our friends are.
So we're going to use the
Social API, to load our list
of friends, onto the page.
And we're going to begin,
by writing a
"registerOnLoadHandler"
function, that calls a
function "init", which calls a
function "loadFriends,"
to load our list of friends.
Within the "loadFriends"
function, we create a new
OpenSocial data request,
add into it requests for the
"viewer" and "viewerFriends"
information, and send the
request to the OpenSocial API.
Where it then calls
"onLoadFriends" once the
data has been returned.
The "onLoadFriends" function
does most of the work.
It pulls out information on the
"viewer" and the "viewerFriends"
from the data object, pushes that
list of friends into a list,
and then displays
the list onto the page.
Finally, we make some small
changes to the gadget XML file,
to allow us to insert the list of
friends into the page.
Now you can see our gadget
in action listing our friends.
For more information on what I
did, and more information on the
Social API, check out the tutorial on
code.google.com under
the Open Social section.